hi i'm rochelle and i'm jana i'm
serenity and today we're making rainbow
sprinkle cake pops this is the perfect
rainbow treat to go with watching the jt
movie now streaming exclusively on
paramount plus i like this recipe
because it's fun it's easy and i get
some time to be with my girls and just
have a little bit of fun and don't worry
about the mess
the best part of baking with my kids is
their little eyes light up they get
super excited to be creative
and just to spend time with each other
in a very happy
fun moment
i like making with my mom because she is
comfortable with us making a mess as a
parent i'm super excited to see the jt
movie especially with the girls i love
dancing i love singing so this is going
to be a great family fun experience i'm
really looking forward to it the jt
movie follows a young girl jojo siwa
who has a dance coach who's retiring
and the new lady that comes in to take
over
strips her away from all her sparkle and
things that make her shine
jojo and her friends start a new dance
team and she rediscovers what dancing
means to her
i like how she's always
singing and dancing she doesn't care
what anyone says about her if they say
oh you can't wear bows she's gonna be
like okay then i don't want to do this
i really like the fact that she is
always so upbeat
and
she seems to have fun no matter where
she's at
and i like how she doesn't turn down
people and she's always so kind
and she just
is very happy and i just like that
she teaches the girls that they can be
themselves and be outgoing and be a
little different and
that it's okay for them to be
just out there and having a good time or
unique
i'm so excited to see this movie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
girls guess what we finally get to try
the cake pops
[Music]
they come out so good
that's really good this is delicious
parents it is the easiest recipe you can
do with your kids this is the perfect
rainbow treat to go with watching the jt
movie now streaming exclusively on
paramount
it'll all be plus